hey youtubers is charlie what's this it
doesn't look like it normally does so
I'm traveling this weekend but I still
wanted to do a couple videos in my arrow
video yesterday I should just admit all
your questions about arrow season 3 as
well as the flash so I picked 10 of them
to answer in this video with one bonus
question thank you so much for all the
bonus video suggestions you guys are
beginning a lot of good ideas if you're
finding me for the first time I do DC
and Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything I also do
Q&A videos like this for really really
big stuff or if there's something that
you guys just want to spend more time
talking about so let's talk about some
villains and Justice League cameos
careful for spoilers from season 2 if
you haven't seen it yet but question
number one Kimberly asks since the
suicide squad will be more prominent on
the show are we to expect the appearance
of Harley Quinn though after her first
cameo this season Andrew Kreisberg said
that they never really planned for her
to be a real character on the show it
was just meant to be an easter egg for
fans even Amell said this really funny
thing recently it was like I never say
never moment someone asked him about
Diggle becoming Jon Stewart the Green
Lantern and he invoked this hollywoodtv
rules thing he just joked that in the
world of TV if it looks really really
good it has a much better chance of
happening I thought Cassidy Alexa looked
great this Harley Quinn but I'm not
expecting her to become a big character
on the show I think we might get another
Easter Egg though question number two
air mill whisperwind asks how will the
timelines work with Oliver and Barry
going on each other shows without
missing their own episodes but you're
asking how Oliver can be in central city
when he's supposed to be on screen in
Starling city what they'll probably do
in a situation like that is right around
the problem so events will be separated
by days like Oliver goes to central city
on a Tuesday but it's back in the new
arrow cave by Wednesday and right now we
have no idea what the crossovers are
going to look like except for what we
saw in the trailer and that was very
visiting Oliver in the first episode of
the flash because both shows are
premiering in the same week arrow
episode one will probably just pick up
the next day from that unless Grant
Gustin comes on arrow which is totally
possible it sounds really really
confusing but it's not so whenever the
show's pick up I'll talk about the
timelines and how everything fits as we
go along in the season question number 3
spent 2 asks which other Justice League
members do you think we'll see next
season I do think we'll see at least one
other cameo beside
the villain that someone from the comics
like a beat or sea level Justice Society
character or maybe even someone from The
Young Justice universe there have been a
lot of rumors that a live-action Young
Justice show could happen in the next
couple of years that's not right around
the corner or anything but I think
anyone they bring on the show will have
spin-off potential it'll be a character
that they can use in another show
question number 4 mm pick asks what role
if any do you think hunters will play in
season 3 so I think that Oliver and
Amanda Waller are going to arrange to
get her out of prison to help out in a
case Andrew Kreisberg already said that
they're continuing to develop the birds
of prey dynamic on the show so think of
hunters coming back in an episode that
feels like a sequel to the birds of prey
this season only this time with the
hunters helping Oliver Laurel and
possibly Sarah if she gets another cameo
it's possible that Laurel could just
occupy it Sarah spot as that Black
Canary character even if she doesn't
become Black Canary yet it would be like
Huntress Laurel and Felicity teaming up
but anyone that has not had their head
you know chopped off is fair game to
come back not just the Huntress question
number 5 Jerry asks do you think they'd
ever jumped forward in time between
seasons in the future like fast forward
no just talking about story devices I
think arrow has really made flashbacks
their thing for better or worse if we do
see flash forwards I think it will be
via the flash show since zoom is a
character that moves around the time a
lot plus Geoff Johns is writing on the
show remember how he wrote the Legion
episode of smallville they could always
do something similar on the flash where
Barry Allen interacts with the Legion of
super-heroes I wouldn't expect something
like that in season one though question
number six don't forget asks can you do
videos saying what you think the writers
could do to make season 3 better than
season 2 who that is going to be tough
so I think there are a couple things
that they have working in their
advantage team arrow is at a low point
even though they defeated Slade the
collateral damage was off the charts so
they're gonna have to go into rebuilding
mode Oliver has to get his company back
rebuild his fortune so they can buy more
cool toys they have to build out that
new arrow cave and they have to
integrate a newly super-powered Barry
into the team I'm totally counting Barry
is a member of team arrow this year even
if he isn't around all the time he is
officially part of the ever growing
family but what a lot of professionals
sports teams do in rebuilding years is
focused on fundamentals so I think we're
going to see some really awesome Oliver
training montages you know rocky style
as he builds a stronger platform for
team arrow to launch you know their
mission of justice from the series takes
a lot of its story cues from Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy but I don't
think we're gonna see a dark knight
rises batman arc for Oliver that would
be like the story they did if the series
ever ended which number seven Ricardo
asks do you think that Solomon Grundy
could be the villain for season three we
could totally see groaning again we
don't really know what happened to him
after the last time we saw him you just
kind of floating around somewhere I do
not think that he's gonna be the main
villain though question number eight
super game Lord asks what if they built
a smallville Clark Lex relationship
between Barry and Eddie you're talking
about Eddie Thawne though I definitely
think that they're going to have some
sort of relationship because they're
gonna be working in the same building I
think that Thawne is going to already
know that Barry is the flash there's a
couple of things going on with his
character it's kind of interesting I
think they're basically combining a bard
Thawne in hunter zolomon abarth on came
from the future and zola man worked with
Barry at the police station the thumb
would only have a reason to kill Barry's
mother if he already knew that Barry was
gonna become the flash someday so he
would have to have knowledge of the
future though the Clark Lex Ren amis
dynamic will be just a little bit
different but they will be working
together so I actually think it's gonna
be really interesting I think it'll be
better than what we saw in Smallville
it's probably gonna take Barry all
season to figure out who Eddie thanas
figure out he has the secret identity is
the reverse-flash but I think that Eddie
is going to know from the start that
Barry is the flash I'm most interested
in how they weave in the time-travel
aspects of the story or maybe they'll
just sidestep it and change the comic
book version of what happened it's hard
to tell before we actually see the pilot
episode question number 9 novisha asks
do you think that Slade will be back
definitely I think it'll be a situation
where like Oliver visits him in prison
to get information on whoever the new
villain is it'll be like Clarice
Starling visiting Hannibal Lecter in
Silence of the Lambs in fact if someone
wants to draw Slade as Hannibal Lecter I
will totally put it in my arrow video
next week if you actually want to do
that just message me on the channel or
just
posted in the comments question number
ten party freak asks what about sin what
about sin I totally hope we get another
Beck's cameo there never told her about
the League of Assassins or the mirakuru
so as far as anyone knows she's still
hanging around the glades I'd really
like to see here get more team ups with
Roy that was one of my favorite episodes
this season and one last bonus question
will excess what about Richard dragon
from the comics being the villain
they've been using him a lot lately
though good suggestion if you're not
familiar in the new 52 comics Richard
dragon is the leader of the long bow
hunters a really notorious group of
green arrow enemies there was even a
really awesome trade paperback story
called long bow hunters that I suggested
as a possible storyline for the show to
adapt in season 3 I do think that
they'll stick within the green arrow
Justice League universe no matter who
they end up picking for the new villain
so thank you so much everyone for so
many questions and thank you for your
patience again since I'm traveling this
weekend I'm probably is getting posting
like one video a day be sure to go see
days of your pass I will be posting a
video for it tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to get it you can actually
click right here to get it all out of
the annotation as soon as I post it and
you can click here to get my top 10
teasers for arrow season 3 thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives